Ми на глибині 437 метрів.
Ми знаходимося у місці, де буде єдине у світі сховище
для остаточного заховання відпрацьованого ядерного палива.
Протягом наступних сотень тисяч років не буде практично жодної небезпеки.
Цей тунель глибоко під землею має змінити ситуацію з ядерними відходами.
Чверть мільйона тонн ядерних відходів нині просто лежать по всьому світу.
У деяких випадках вони виділяють токсини в навколишнє середовище.
І ніхто достеменно не знає, що з ними робити.
Окрім фінів.
Тож як їм це вдалося?
Коли я вперше почула, що фіни будують сховище для ядерних відходів,
я подумала, що воно буде десь у глибинці
- можливо, за полярним колом.
Але ні, насправді це лише три години їзди автівкою від Гельсінкі.
У муніципалітеті з населенням майже 10 тисяч осіб під назвою Еурайокі.
Тут також знаходиться найбільший в Європі ядерний реактор.
Муніципалітет подав заявку на розміщення майданчика
і був обраний серед чотирьох можливих місць.
Будівництво розпочалося у 2004 році.
Насправді це диво, що так сталося.
Адже сховище для остаточного зберігання відпрацьованого ядерного палива
має утримувати високорадіоактивні відходи від витоку в навколишнє середовище
протягом кількох сотень тисяч років.
Якщо подумати глобально, то за цей час настануть і минуть кілька льодовикових періодів.
Це потребує десятиліть обговорень, планування,
ретельного вибору майданчиків та інженерного подвигу.
Інші країни з атомними електростанціями також шукали власні постійні сховища,
але ніхто ще навіть не розпочав будівництво.
Незалежно від того, чи є ви прихильником або противником ядерної енергетики,
ця проблема потребує швидкого вирішення.
Тому що у всьому світі відходи накопичуються
в подекуди непідготовлених тимчасових сховищах.
Але не у Фінляндії:
Після десятиліть досліджень і будівництва сховище,
яке фінською мовою називається "Онкало", тобто "печера" або "яма",
має запрацювати в найближчі кілька років.
Ми готові!
Дорога вниз займає майже 15 хвилин.
Ми спустилися на глибину 437 метрів.
Тут дійсно наче в печері.
Навколо нас - кристалічні корінні породи, суміш граніту та гірської породи
під назвою мігматит.
І це перша підказка до того, чому саме це місце
було обрано для зберігання ядерних відходів.
Вік скелі - майже два мільярди років.
Вона досить непорушна. Досить суха.
У нас тут не так багато руху підземних вод.
Антті Йоутсен – головний геолог у компанії, яка опікується об'єктом.
Вміщувальна порода не має бути економічно вигідною для того,
що майбутні покоління не хотіли б витягти її зі скелі.
Але знайти потрібну породу - лише перший крок.
Адже ядерні відходи не схожі на будь-які інші.
Існує три основні типи ядерних відходів:
низькоактивні, середньоактивні та високоактивні.
Низькоактивні відходи - це зазвичай речі,
які контактували з радіоактивними матеріалами.
Наприклад, захисне обладнання, фільтри або медичні відходи.
Відходи середньої активності - це обладнання,
що використовується на атомних станціях або у виробництві зброї.
Наприклад, труби чи ізоляційні матеріали.
Вони можуть залишатися радіоактивними протягом кількох сотень років.
Їх дезактивують і ховають у низькоактивних сховищах під землею або над землею.
До 99 відсотків усіх ядерних відходів підпадає під цю категорію.
І лише один відсоток високоактивних радіоактивних відходів
є найбільш проблематичним.
Вони складаються здебільшого з відпрацьованих ядерних паливних стрижнів.
Але сюди також входять відходи від виробництва ядерної зброї.
Ці відходи знаходяться або в басейнах-охолоджувачах,
або в сухих бочках - загалом понад чверть мільйона метричних тонн.
Це стільки ж, скільки важать 26 Ейфелевих веж.
З деяких відходів витікає радіоактивний матеріал.
Найкраще рішення для безпечного поводження з ними
- поховати їх глибоко під землею і залишити розкладатися
на кілька сотень тисяч років, поки вони не стануть безпечними.
Щоб запобігти витоку радіоактивних відходів зі стрижнів за цей час,
їх потрібно належним чином укрити.
У Фінляндії відпрацьовані паливні стрижні
запечатують у мідні каністри товщиною 5 сантиметрів
і висотою близько 5 метрів.
Потім їх транспортують під землю за допомогою підіймача.
У корінних породах вздовж дуже довгих тунелів свердлять отвори.
Потім каністри поміщають в отвори.
Нічого собі! Тут так глибоко, що я чую власний відгомін.
Отвір засипають бентонітовою глиною,
яка також використовується як наповнювач
для котячого туалету і може поглинати ґрунтові води,
які можуть просочуватися всередину і роз'їдати мідну каністру.
І, нарешті, тунель засипається тим самим матеріалом і закривається 6-метровою бетонною плитою.
Ці капсули або контейнери - найбільш суперечлива складова
всього сховища ядерних відходів.
Що станеться, якщо шар бентоніту матиме дефекти або буде пошкоджений?
Тоді ґрунтові води, що містять сульфіди та водень, потраплять до контейнерів.
У численних дослідженнях вчені довели, що мідь може піддатися корозії,
і контейнери вийдуть з ладу набагато швидше,
ніж розраховувала відповідальна компанія - можливо, вже через десятиліття.
Дослідження тривають і ця тема широко обговорюється в науковій спільноті.
Але позиція фінського агентства з ядерної безпеки та компанії Posiva
в тому, що ризик не надто значний.
Контейнер - це лише один захисний шар з багатьох, наголошують вони.
В "Онкало" в майбутньому зберігатимуться
всі відходи з наявних фінських атомних електростанцій.
Наразі невідомо як майбутні покоління
зможуть визначити, що радіоактивні відходи знаходяться саме тут
- і чи потрібно їх зберігати немаркованими.
Та навіть попри це Фінляндія випереджає більшість країн.
Можливо, через свій унікальний менталітет.
Однією з причин може бути прагматичне мислення фінського народу.
Існує взаємний консенсус, що ми повинні дбати про відходи.
Не залишати їх майбутнім поколінням.
Опору з боку суспільства було небагато.